[Applause]
third straight win
three wins in four days
and the hornets back to the 500 mark at
five and five theme is growing right
before our eyes
a lot of young players that love to play
the game love to go to work
coachable and they like playing with
each other
well folks don't go anywhere we're going
to talk to lamela ball right now
we're going to get his thoughts just
moments after his first
nba triple double what a special talent
precocious talent 19 years of age
and doing work against adults grown men
in the best basketball league in the
world his brother alonzo said last night
he's been playing
up which means he's been playing against
older bigger
guys his entire life and when you do
that you have to learn
how to affect the game how to play
against grown men guys bigger than you
so when you get here you're not in all
you just continue to do what you've done
all your life
you've become real good at zola bella
was uh
one assist away from a triple-double
yesterday
and he said i think i can do a little
bit better he gets that triple double
uh 24 hours later finishes with 22
points
12 rebounds and 11 assists
left no doubt about the triple double
all right lavello's standing by right
now hey lamelo congratulations this is
eric and dell up in the booth
uh fantastic work i'm sure you know but
your first
nba triple double how does it feel uh i
mean i feel great we got the win so yeah
i'm feeling great right now
how is it that you're able to come back
after playing
an emotional night last night in new
orleans your brother to
quickly turn around and then play the
game that you had here tonight
right like i said it's just basketball
and i'm doing what i love i mean i've
been doing this
ever since i was three so it comes quite
easy to me for real
lamela i would think the rebounding
would be the hardest part of a triple
double for you you weigh 181 pounds
uh but it looks like you're a natural
rebounder what's the key during that
i mean i played a lot of 21 growing up
so it's just a whole lot of basketball
for real
it's pretty much just instincts i guess
how is it playing against trey young you
guys have really played well against him
he's yet to hit a three in two games
struggled really
what's been the key there guarding him
pretty much just locking in on him
closing
in i mean coach had a uh grace garden
report and we just following it pretty
much
my voice you already know all right
lavello paint the picture for me you
guys
are gonna have a day off tomorrow you
don't play again until monday night
against the knicks
uh your agenda for tomorrow how do you
plan on enjoying your day off
pretty much just chilling with my boy jj
in the film and then probably go in the
gym get some shots up
and then on to the next day and i'm
gonna give you the last word
uh two dunks that just uh brought my
hair to a standstill
yeah terry rozier in the first half
caleb martin in the second half
which dunk do you take as the best of
the night ah both of my boys but
damn that's tough t-rowe had a cold move
to a dunk but yeah caleb's was kayla's
tough i like the one leg
good answer man thank you for your time
lamelo hey keep on keeping on you've
been a joy to watch so far yes sir thank
you family
zola mello ball in his 10th nba game
history a triple double deltoid's family
that's pretty cool